hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to let's play nevermind a
biofeedback horror game and if you've
never heard what a biofeedback horror
game is it's because there aren't any
others and this one was sent to me by
the lovely people who developed it and
in addition to the game that they sent
me they sent me this heart rate monitor
that I currently have strapped to my
muscular chest and I'm gonna be going
through this game with this monitoring
my heart rate and I have a feeling that
it's getting a little fuzzier because
maybe my heart rate is picking up when
I'm talking as opposed to sitting here
alone so anyway there was a bit of an
intro to this game you are a scientist
who is trying to help people rebuild
their memories and as far as I know you
need to collect these particular
memories here and piece them in in a
proper order so me having a tea party it
was so hot that day I remember being so
thirsty so when you click it it'll go up
into order but because I don't have any
other ones yet I need to find out the
correct order that they go in and I
think these are dated so anyway let's
get into it there was a rather long
intro sequence that I wanted to get you
guys to see what the gaming was all
about so I'm gonna go in here okay I got
my volume turned way up and my pants are
off as per usual let's see what this
actually means to have a biofeedback
horror game okay
oh flashing images slamming doors you're
gonna have to do better than that
picture of people weird spiral lamp
okay that'll do it blood smeared all
over the walls oh that lovely picture is
gone now good oh and someone messed with
the D party okay all right
still not scary what have you got for me
Oh love-love money card done jigsaw milk
shot what do these have to do with each
other I have no idea ah it's not money
money money I don't know what it is
money money money
yeah is it good all right it's dark in
here
Oh what happened to that guy's face oh
okay
oh hello why did I need to grab that gun
permit oh okay I think I'm starting to
piece together the mystery of this place
someone went a little loopy crazy
okay so do I need to clean up what then
excuse me oh I got a hold it okay so
okay all right then
mildly disconcerting I still don't know
where the biofeedback part of it comes
into play I don't see a heart rate
monitor that seems like something that
would be really neglected in this or
there's no visual indicator okay there's
no visual in oh okay ah mommy's favorite
drink was grown-up grape juice it
smelled gross okay good grown-up grape
juice mm the balance part of everybody's
breakfast what is that
besides to hold animals hanging up the
Scylla
I owe the solution that which lies
before you can be realized through that
which has been left behind
Oh so the solutions that oh okay I got
it okay so it's to do with this it has
to do with this this
this is a word milk gun sorrow milk gun
and sorrow okay I got it
okay I got it I think milk because those
were cows gone and sorrow daddy and his
letters he never wanted to play after
the mailman brought new ones Oh God
that'll be useful for when I'm blown
away all those monsters what I'm just
cocking it I'm cocking it but I ain't
doing nothing
shooting blanks okay so all the doors
open okay good for me okay oh okay
that's a little weird
alrighty then bathe in wolves I'd rather
bathe in water if you don't mind I
wanted to drink so I tried to pour some
milk I made such a mess I should tell
mom or dad by bathing in woes do you
mean I'm about to have a fun Wow I'm not
bathing in whoa I'm bathing a no-no what
what is ha ha ha oh stop it what are you
doing why are you shooting milk
everywhere I stop it stop it stop it
what are you doing
what happened my drowning out how do I
not drown okay is that part of the bio
fee oh my white is bone that is one
ominous frickin refrigerator I've ever
seen one now what what is that what is
that no no no not again
neat going upstairs mommy was busy so I
went to find daddy he was usually
working I don't wanna know what that is
Oh God again I don't know if that
actually is related to my heartbeat have
these weird things strapped to my chest
click to reset what what look to reset
what what I'm not sure with the whole
leave your worries at the door I'm more
worried about that sign okay no no no
too bad I'm asking you
oh that looks happy what hello
someone here what the hell is this these
oh okay no no no no no no no how about
now oh good a jigsaw I can't why is it
getting blurry I'm gonna just get the
Diggs out pieces here I'm gonna go on my
way okay okay
lovely lovely oh my what the hell is
going on there that is a weird why is it
looking at me okay all right
there was another there was another
chick selfies down here
oh this strap is uncomfortable around my
boobs oh I get it okay so no maybe yeah
it's like he's these things really
aren't sure if they actually want to go
where I'm telling them to go okay
anyway I really do think that's part of
the biofeedback of it that is that is
quite interesting tenet does that and it
found my one weakness mannequins yeah I
wish I had like a flashlight or
something cuz I can't see where these
pieces are if I lose them yeah I don't
think I've gotten them all there's got
to be more oh okay oh now that
everything's calmed down you can finally
oh look at you what is wrong with you oh
you're so weird
oh my god that is disgusting
I'm sorry for disturbing you okay calm
down calm down huh take a deep breath
okay maybe I shouldn't get near those
things maybe that's something that I
shouldn't do I really wish I really wish
and it seems like a vastly overlooked
feature to not be able to see my heart
rate as I'm playing this am I done
stay away from the heads I can see them
looking at me this is my least oh good
plate okay okay
puzzle bills mmm little girl mommy and
daddy with no head car well the doors
open
glad I can leave this place of Horrors
behind
shut up okay what do we have now
no what did I miss
did something change I don't know if
anything changed
what went different go away okay so I I
guess I'm done
oh okay I may have enough memories now
so I just got to reorganize him okay so
1 to 70 to 100 see so the first one
probably the Tea Party but ah mommy
happy
mommy drinking daddy bills girl-girl no
that's not the right order I don't think
this is quite correct maybe something
else here let me look around a bit
because there's bound to be a bit more
that I've missed
okay that doors blocked off but I think
I saw something over here now the
objective of what I'm doing here
apparently as a worker scientist of this
crazy place is I'm trying to heal them
by making them remember what is that oh
oh it's coming out of their brains is
that milk okay so know if I have
anything else maybe I just got to fit
them all together okay so the only room
that I can still go into is the kitchen
so is there something else here that I
need with this click to reset oh oh okay
I see so be a tea all bathe in is what
it is a bathe in whoa
oh whoops it's bathed with an e in whoa
oh no no no no I'm bathing in milk
nuttin woes bathing woes whoa is that
what it meant by woes Oh what are these
things why do I need to Beus them where
am i boosting them to you why
oh hi what the hell is with this place
is a dead end
thank you can't see wish I could see
would like some light light would be
delightful okay I've made a initial
error I need to follow the milk that's
what I need to do get out of my way you
weird twitching body bags
oh you weird maggot filled earth get off
me you dick
oh no I'm gonna drown again you need to
calm down
I think that's triggered by a little
something some irate hello
nope dead end I can't see the milk on
the ground the way it goes here oh no no
no no no no no no no no no I got it
damn look go this way I don't even know
if that's what I would call milk yeah
kids get away from me weirdo okay what
is this ah Lakes eating breakfast alone
okay oh there's the milk goody-goody
milk
I got the milk I don't know what that
means now what do I do seriously what do
I do
no no no no I'm out of here
I'm out of here baby I don't think I
need to be in there
too bad okay so I'm old I'm all done
there okay I think I've officially
gotten everything I needed from inside
now I just got to piece this together
okay I was spending so much time for
solving the puzzle over there that I had
no idea that this opened up over here
okay oh that's weird so suddenly there's
cars now what does that mean for me what
do I have to do how do I solve it what
steps to oh I'm playing Frogger okay
well let's play the game let's play the
feud nailed it okay so someone had a car
accident he died in a car accident mommy
said she was so sad she hated question
okay happened okay I'm sorry I'm
terribly sorry about all my dresses I've
ever done in my entire life okay all
right music back again where do I go
what do I do
okay what do we do oh no dead end
Oh
they go wrong way oh I see
I don't know what I've done shut up this
is weird
Hey
Oh
Hey
wait a minute yeah that's what I thought
there's another way what's over there
hang on what's over here
okay nothing hang on I gotta see what's
up no no no there's got to be nothing
god that is getting annoying series hi
this is going good I can tell
this is going real good I am figuring it
out what are you figuring out oh it's
covered in hands
okay
all right
I keep going down I don't know what else
that wants from me
at first it was ah here we go okay hi
buddy
yep get out of my way please okay got
the thing oh now is someone shooting
themselves oh my goodness it's the bad
tree from creepy okay so what's up with
you in your face shut up
she's you dramatic music bastards
alright just checking to see if they're
okay
that is so creepy this is so creepy
oh so I'm guessing you finally figured
out that your dad didn't die in a car
didn't so I still have an issue here I
can't seem to sort more than five of
them oh okay
who are these people
No okay ow
what the hell are you doing you [ __ ]
how do I get through here stop moving
stop doing the Samba and let me through
I'm about to be squashed I'm about to be
squished by you do shoes okay sort of
getting used to you looking at me so how
about we just take a big deep breath and
calm down huh and let me through
letting me through would be good oh I
see
whoop all right I got it okay you said
wheels what okay so so what about this
okay
need to fill you up with milk and then
make you go this might take a while
everybody cuz I don't know what they're
trying to get from me I'm guessing I'm
trying to make these things go in a good
order
I don't know what they'd all say one for
me you think I only have enough to make
them go off milk for everybody yeah
there we go okay all right then you go
there no come back here you little deuce
you go there and that'll do it right
that should do it I think unless that
big one needs more that big one needs
more it's not quite on there okay how
about now
all right there we go there we go there
we go gotta gotta gotta gotta go
Oh
didn't realize you were actually in
there what is daddy eating Oh
was daddy eating a gun okay yeah you
still looking at me whatever just move
on Oh
this game has a penchant for inanimate
things looking it what did you say to me
what did you say to me you want to
repeat that to me don't speak mine first
sure you work for okay so I think I have
all that I need so ha ha ha ha what do I
do
okay so I need to put these in order
right that's what I need to do this one
needs to happen so the story needs to be
told correctly
ah there we go I was playing tea party
and I got thirsty so I went inside to
pour myself a glass of milk it slipped
from my hands and spilled everywhere I
went to tell my mom but she was taking a
shower so I went to tell my father he
was upstairs in his bedroom and when I
opened the door he had a gun in his
mouth he looked at me and and then he
shot himself he shot himself it was so
terrible I couldn't remember what
happened so my mom she must have made up
the story of the car accident to protect
me from ever remembering but I guess I
always knew that was a lie I always knew
there we go okay I had to think
objectively about it I had to think you
know that it wasn't all in a series
events that it was all just parts of it
I spent boy but good ten minutes just
staring at it for a bit before I finally
got that and you got a piece of story
together from the important parts like I
actually read it and on the beginning
that tea party said I was so thirsty so
I thought oh so thirsty went to get a
drink that's how it happened okay so
there it is Wow all right this was the
intro sequence set I told you about that
I skipped over in the beginning it was
just I'm a bunch of going like hey we
here at the Institute work here to heal
people's minds so oh okay I gotcha
I think that was the end of this one and
her Erin Reynolds creative director
Monst Attenborough's Nick and then I'm
assuming a whole bunch of other ones
this is an interesting way to put some
credits I apologize that I don't have
time to stop and read everyone's epitaph
here it's not a Canon it's a stick of
dynamite that's disturbing
Oh what is going on here I saw shiny ok
that's nothing it's eerily quiet but I'm
assuming this is just the Hall of
credits here
okey-dokey and there you go that is
never mind or at least that is the early
preview of never mind that you guys get
to see right now and the game is
currently being attempted to be funded
on Kickstarter there's a link in the
description below I highly recommend it
that was thoroughly scary even though I
had no idea how exactly the heart rate
monitor was affecting my experience in
the game I kind of inferred something by
the static and the different things
happening and like the scares
compounding on scares that was really
cool but I would love to see some sort
of feedback on what's actually happening
because otherwise I'm just guessing and
I'm not entirely sure although it could
be good to just guess because then you
kind of left it odds and you don't know
what's happening so you don't know if
it's actually happening either way this
was fun thank you so much to developers
for sending me this game and sending me
the heart rate monitor which couldn't
have been cheap this is a very high
quality model they're working on
something so that everyone can use a
cheaper model or any model but this one
in particular I think pretty pricey so
thank you guys so much for watching
thank you developers for giving it a try
giving this to be try and as always I
will see you in the next video
buh-bye
of the